I look so tall.
I'm so tall.
I'm standing proud.
Hello everybody!
It's past midnight and I'm also jet lagged.
Jet lagging.
I hope it's not as bad with you.
you, Minky.
I just woke up.
I'm a little sick, everybody.
Sorry.
But I'm home.
I'm home.
Oh, Bito and Ibu is like you.
Welcome home, Bito.
We missed you.
Thank you.
Bito has grown so much.
I feel tall.
Maybe if I'm Like full standing.
I don't feel as tall.
I'm so, I'm too leggy.
I'm too leggy.
Look back tall, Minky.
Since you're so tall, can I get a head pat?
But me?
Only because I'm sick and I want to feel better.
You may pat.
I'm sick again.
And I also was just like...
I feel like I want to stand for this game.
Peak Cross.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, uh, uh, uh, Peak Cross.
It's been a minute since I last did a Nono Grams.
So I'm excited.
Helping you feel better soon.
Thank you!
I should.
I, I should.
Peak Cross.
So true.
And this one came out recently.
This is Peacross Konami Antiques Edition.
And uh...
I did check.
And a certain...
Oh my gosh, look at the Tokimeki.
A certain Sneaking Man might be in the game!
Me and Ty, thank you for the gift.
Is Peacross the game where it looks like Sudoku, but you're
making pixel art?
Yes.
I do no-no grams quite literally every single day of my
afterlife.
I play no-no grams every day!
Actually, I'm stuck on one right now on Meow Tower.
But I don't know.
I just thought that this would be...
Wait, what's a Mega P-Cross?
What's a...
Play Color P-Cross?
What's Clip?
P-P-P-P-P-P-P?
Peacross.
I think I'm just going to do normal Peacross.
Wait, what is color Peacross?
Welcome to the world of Peacross.
I don't need a tutorial.
I know what I'm doing.
It unlocks.
I said it was my birthday.
Hey, Paul!
Happy birthday!
Sorry I missed it.
Clip is just smaller puzzles.
Oh.
I see why are they why are they afraid to show metal gear in
the background why are they afraid look at the hockey oh
yeah we yeah we yeah does anyone still watch that?
Wait, um, uh, the burning, um, what's it called?
Uh, what was it called?
Raging flames?
Um, the hockey yowie.
Oh,
welcome back, Rito.
Let me feel better soon.
Beat the jet hag.
Yeah, thank you.
Can't stick around for the whole stream, unfortunately, but
I hope I'm in peak classes.
Thank you, future beyond!
Hey, Vito.
So, you know, after a very long work week, your playthrough
of A Wolf Among Us was the pinnacle of my week.
Please consider playing more games where you decide the
outcome.
It was perfect.
Really?
Yeah, does people like the Wolf Among Us?
I had a lot of fun playing it.
So...
To say it was my birthday, Death Pudgeon!
Happy birthday!
Thank you for the surprise Twitter space on my birthday.
I did do that.
Had a lot of fun watching.
Let's see.
Let's get into a game and then we get...
Here, this one's only five by five.
Let me explain to you how P-Cross works, everybody.
Wait, what is this?
Use a button or stick to quickly switch between...
Let's touch Tog.
Impo will be turned on off every time the button or stick is
pressed.
I think Tog.
Well, maybe.
I'll change it if I don't like it.
Use the hint roulette?
What's that?
No.
Okay, everybody.
Let's sensei minto.
Teach you how to play P. Cross.
five right here that means that there are five spaces that
will be filled of the grid so we can just go wait wait how
do I do it we could just wait wait wait how do I how do I
input it wait maybe I should have buttoned it wait wait wait
I'm confused.
Buttons.
Okay.
We filled in the five and it grayed out.
Then you see a one and a two.
That means that one space in here and also two spaces must
be filled in.
But they cannot touch.
So it could be one.
space two or one space two or one space space two things
like that as you can see on the left here we also have the
left side the one has already built been filled in but we
have the three which means that there are still three more
spaces that need to be filled in so we go up to the very
tippy top and then Wait, how do I...
Okay, I'm guessing...
So we know that these are all X's because there was only one
space to be filled in horizontally, but also because there
are ones here.
And like I said earlier, the ones cannot touch the twos or
the three.
Then we go down here, one, two, three.
Oh, one, two, three.
That already takes care of our one and our two.
two.
We can fill that in.
So what we're left with is one and three.
And it's really easy when it's on a bottom because you can
just do as many up as you need to.
And then also on the left is one, one.
So one here and then one.
It's going to be all the way on the other side.
Easy.
Yes, Sensei teaches you.
what oh it's a gold flag thanks teach here let's do let's do
one here we'll do one more five by five and then we'll move
to something difficult I'll do this one real fast I'll show
you no hint roulette I don't even know what that is what's a
hint Minto math mastermind see you then let's see You can
fill these in, right?
This one gets filled in.
This all gets filled in.
Which means this gets filled in.
Which means this all gets filled in.
It's a bell?
Twin bee!
Thanks for making it make sense, Min-tao-sensei.
Nice lesson.
Thank you, thank you.
We could probably do these really quickly though.
How have you guys been?
Oh, what did I do?
What did I do that I can talk about?
There was one thing that we did.
Actually, I think part of the reason I got sick is...
Is, um...
Oh.
Oh, I didn't mean to do that.
Wait, turn auto-correct off?
Yes.
Oh, I just held the butt in my butt.
We were recording something.
And I think it made me sick.
because holy cow.
I think Phoebe and I got permanent brain damage.
Today is my birthday!
Dante!
Happy birthday!
Can I get that mother base happy birthday?
Happy birthday.
Happy birthday was all you did.
Oh, we're already on 10.
Wait, hold on.
Oh, we're already at 10.
Nice.
May your scar stay blue.
Happy birthday to you.
I think it gave us brain damage because...
Um...
The mold.
And then Phoebe was getting something out that she needed
to...
That we needed to use.
And spiders came out.
The place was just entirely cursed.
Like we opened up the doors and we were coughing.
We were like, it just smelled like cleaning supplies and
mold and everything.
It was so awful.
Oh, don't the blue ones mean that I can, they're solvable?
Pretty sure.
I think so.
Not mold and spiders.
I think we like got...
We were like...
We were like, are we gonna be okay after this?
Got my jazz concert merch, it's so good.
I saw a lot of people getting their jazz merch!
That's so exciting.
I'm blaming Steiner for this.
Actually, you can, because he...
He booked the place.
He booked it, so...
Actually, you can blame him.
What is the hint?
I'm so curious.
Oh.
What's happening?
No!
We just filled that hole.
Wait, that's no fun.
Wait, that's so boring.
Wait, that's
so boring.
I love your playthrough of the wolf.
Not all your choices were ones I would have picked.
That was fun seeing the different paths.
Me and my cat currently laid on my lap.
I want my cat in my lap.
Help you feel better quickly.
Thank you, Phil!
Let's see what else we got here.
See, like, so you can do this.
You can, it's all, it's all a puzzle, everybody.
It's just a puzzle.
So here, for example, you're like, why'd you put that two
there?
Well, I put the one here, as the one indicated here, and
then there's the other one there, as indicated here.
There's three slots, so it must at least be in the middle.
I wonder if I could change the music.
Is it going to be this song every time?
I wonder when we'll get Metal Gear.
Uh, how many you want?
One, two, three, four, five.
What is that?
Mahjong?
Talisman.
I got a clip P cross piece as a bonus for clearing the
puzzle.
You get it now!
No.
It's actually so easy.
I think it's much easier than Sudoku.
Can't wait to cosplay you for Dokami!
I can't wait to see!
Thank you!
See, these are easy.
Oh, whoops.
Oh, we can easily figure out that A.
We can figure out this 10.
out okay everything else is done okay that's done this is a
two this is a one this is a oh this one is done it is done
Pete Cross like relaxes me so much anyone else sure you've
heard plenty about Forza Horizon 6's gotcha radio is totally
your thing and you could give us a tour I haven't heard
anything.
Wait, what do you mean?
This is all news.
Wait, what are we saying?
What's happening?
Who's... Who's a what's a?
Forza Horizon 6 is in Japan.
It's set in Japan this time.
Why are you telling me because I'm a wikibu or something?
Thing Japan.
Minto, thing Japan.
It's a racing game.
There's other racing games that have been set in Japan.
Oh, does it want me to...
Oh, okay.
It wants you to...
Okay, let's see what else we got.
This is all done.
still need uh let's see this is done i'm getting lost in the
size
let's see four two oh here we go there we go i've
never tried putting on my my eye patch and my glasses at the
oh i can i can put on my eye patch and my glasses at the
same time wait it kind of It's kind of goofy.
It looks like I have a scar on my face.
Whoa.
Snake's revenge.
That's so funny that they included that.
I kind of want to do a bigger puzzle, though.
Who's with me?
You love Pete Cross, too?
Let's go.
I love Pete Cross.
what we got over on this side.
Still 10x10.
What is...
Oh, 15x15.
Let's try 15x15.
I am Nanogram VTuber.
Yeah, that's me.
Oh, the good smell.
Wait, I gotta change.
I wanna see if I can change the music.
Oh!
Oh, yay!
Good smell, good smell.
I hope you feel better, Minto.
I just got back from New York after my surgery.
I'm doing good so far, even with the left of my head is
numb.
Fire, Sun!
Rest well!
This one's nice.
Be careful, Minto.
There are bombs and bombs go boom!
You also know forces get... Wait.
Also, did you know forces get...
It's gonna be in Japan?
Japan, Japan, Japan!
I wonder who this guy is.
Oh, this one's classic.
This one is...
Whoa!
Did Goemon ever come to the West?
Let's do shuffle, we'll shuffle, we'll shuffle.
We'll shuffle, we'll shuffle.
Some Goemon games dead.
Oh, really?
Some of them dead.
It was called Legend of the Mystical Ninja.
Sanji, thank you so much for the thought.
I get it.
Thank you.
All right, let's see where we start here.
Now, you may always think, like, what is she doing?
But I have a method to my madness.
There's always a method to the madness.
But yeah, what else did I do?
I don't think.
It was like a whirlwind of everything.
My sister spawn, are you sick too?
I fell off my bike while going down a dirt trail today and
spring my shoulder.
Feel better!
Oh my gosh.
That's scary.
Bikes are scary.
How many times to visit cafes or idol lives?
I went to one idol show, actually.
And I got so much inspiration.
Not gonna lie.
I was like, for the Densetsu 3D concert, I was like, I was
like taking notes.
I was like, boom, boom, boom, boom, boom.
I want to do this and that for our 3D show too.
So actually, it was a very fruitful experience.
Yes, yes.
Do you hear that I-Mouse is at Asen right now?
Yeah, I did.
I was like, of course they bring over like everybody.
A year that I can't go.
That's okay though.
I'm happy to be back at my cafe.
Happy to be back streaming.
Yeah.
Honestly.
This song is so short.
All the cons are popping right now, mega-fomo.
Yeah!
But there will always be more cons, so...
We're glad to have you back.
There are people that never get to go, you know, because
they live so far away or something.
So honestly...
I'm just grateful that I can go to some of them sometimes.
There will always be more conventions.
That person?
Me.
No!
I hope one day I can meet everybody, though.
That's my wish.
I want to see everybody's cute little faces.
What if we just make Ibukon?
Welcome back, we don't miss you so much.
Hope you feel better soon.
Hey, cute.
Why?
Why are you sending Aqua Swoop?
I look like this, by the way.
I know, so cute.
So cute.
There's like this TikTok audio going around right now.
That's kind of like my...
I kept doing...
I kept doing it to...
Not to Steiner, but like say...
I told Steiner about it too.
Because I was just like, I can't stop saying this.
And it's like this guy.
I don't know what the context is of it at all.
But it just goes...
Aw.
So cute.
cute and people keep putting it over their pets and stuff
and so i'm always like oh so cute so cute i cannot stop
saying it context she's watching vince no no no no no
what else we got that we can complete um i'm like not locked
in at all but that's okay
raiders hello welcome we are playing peak rolls
oh my goodness oh the gift is so cute it's also happy about
me though i know why do I couldn't ride and so cute and pop
off.
Thank you, thank you.
Rest of glitch face.
Thank you.
Bear that.
Thank you, Darko.
Thank you.
Phil, thank you.
We can still have to thank you.
I'm sure Steiner appreciated you calling him cute.
No, I wasn't towards him.
Hot dog lump you?
Wait, why is your name the bestest ever?
Wait, that sounds so delicious.
I was just thinking today, all I want is Taco Bell.
Come on.
Thank you for the money given.
Thank you.
All I want is Taco Bell.
Taco Bell heals everything.
I wouldn't go that far, but it is, you know.
It's yummy.
It's like, I don't know.
American comfort.
What the hell is the song of...
I'm becoming stupid.
How can you like Taco Bell?
How can you dislike Taco Bell?
Not all of us are on the West Coast for other delicacies.
Some of us only have Taco Bell, okay?
That's all we've got.
some of us are not so privileged Taco Bell is literally
every drunk ingredient that tastes good I agree
yeah tell them it is actually on the cheaper side right I
don't know anymore right now though they've raised some of
their prices I'm like dang it's really not much for a for a
five layer anymore if you get the box though it's like
cheaper I think some afterlife hacks with me minkey get the
box so far I'm seeing a bearded man but I wonder what it
will be this
is not 13 yeah what's my Go to order, either, either,
Crunchyrap Supreme, Crunchyrap Supreme.
Or, beefy five layer, or two tacos, Supreme.
No, I didn't get to try the Baja Blast Pie, which I probably
should have made more of an effort to, I have an awful cold
right now too.
No, Kira!
Why?
The fact that you're super jealous in yen.
No, Kira!
Get better.
Oh, that's the worst, being sick on a trip.
This song is five seconds long.
I don't think they really thought through these song
choices.
One,
two, three.
Crunch wrap, add potatoes?
Potatoes!
I mean, they'll help you feel better soon.
Also, I got you this fresh burrito.
Thank you so much for your offering, Eric!
Ow, ow, ow, ow, ow.
I can't move my head up too much or down.
I...
It hurt.
Tummy horde?
No.
Head horde.
What are your thoughts on the Mexican pizza?
I've never had that.
A Taco Bell?
Wow, I don't understand why I end up talking about Taco Bell
so much on my channel.
I don't know how that always happens, guys.
Sorry.
You know?
Maybe I'm just a fan.
Yeah, okay.
Give me the sponsor.
Oh, that was it.
Oh, that looks like a ship.
Keep talking about Taco Bell.
Oh, it's the Vic Viper.
It's in my Mexican blood.
I think that's...
If I were, I think talking about Taco Bell so much would be
against that, no?
But also, I'm a reincarnated Japanese princess.
As per my taxi driver.
Okai-ri-bito!
Miss you lots.
Really appreciated the time and effort you put into the
Let's Plays while you were gone.
It was really nice to turn into.
I hope you feel better soon.
Thank you!
I'm really glad that you guys like those when I go away.
Taxi driver is correct.
Yeah, I just...
Sorry, I'm a reincarnated Japanese princess.
As a fellow sinus sufferer, you tried flushing with saline
solution.
I think ectoplasm is kind of saline-ish already.
Maybe?
What am I made of?
I need science done on me.
Not to repeat, but dancing queen confused my friends at
karaoke.
Okay.
I'm so glad.
It's salty?
Maybe.
If I lick my arm.
Three crunchy tacos.
Just beef.
Cheese and fire sauce!
Are you trying to send me to the after afterlife?
Hope you feel better soon, Vinta.
Thank you!
Did you have a chance to try the giant cheese?
Cheese it?
Crunch wrap.
Is that still happening?
Sounds like it's not because you're saying that I have the
chance to try it.
It doesn't sound like it's still around anymore.
Oh!
I got scared.
We are ready to do science on you.
Why is there no good ghost footage?
You know?
Actually, I can tell you why.
It's because we're all too goofy.
Try.
Try to screencap me right now.
No one will believe you.
Oh, I'm over here.
No, I'm over here.
Now I'm picking up fear.
Now I'm big.
Now I'm tiny.
Now I'm an ant.
Now I'm really big.
Now I'm even bicker.
Now I'm taking over the screen in your computer.
Okay, I just downloaded.
I'm hacking.
I'm in some...
died.
Your computer.
Oh.
Delete, delete, delete, delete, delete, delete, delete.
Delete!
Delete it all!
I saved you.
You know what I wish I could have done?
I wish I could have erased my history before I died.
I just saved you all.
The embarrassment.
What if I was one P cross I?
Thank you, Minto.
I'm thinking of you.
Of you.
NRG shock.
Welcome to Mambusha.
Thank you.
I'm picking up an EVP here.
Oh, God.
It's Moe.
It's all Moe.
I'll be having a good Saturday.
Years ago.
Minto, it's my birthday today.
You are my favorite Vtuber.
Thank you.
Oh, thank you.
Oh, my birthday.
Wait, how do I say your name?
La, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la, la,
la, la, la,
la, la, I'm playing the game.
Oh, easy.
Wait, one, two, three, four, five, six, seven, eight, nah.
Nice.
See, B-cross is so easy.
Everybody.
Big horse is so easy.
You just follow a number.
A number come to you.
Sometimes I get stuck, though.
Not gonna lie.
It says that we could...
Oh, okay, that's...
Wait, this is a person!
I went to screenshot during that and the video died.
I have a screenshot of nothing!
Freaky!
This music is...
This is penis music.
Quit it!
Cut it out!
Oh wait, did I just mess this up?
Wait, no.
Right?
Wait.
Yeah.
So I think it's like that.
You guys know.
I didn't make that term up.
I promise.
What is this?
It looks like a slime man.
Looks like a slime guy, maybe?
Oh, this one's good.
Let's see.
Two, three, this four and one can be done, or something can
be done with it.
It says we could do something with this one.
But what?
I got my massive Minto Fumo.
She's actually baby sized.
I tried to warn you all.
I tried to say that the Minto Fumo is not, not, you are not
ready for its size.
I tried to warn you all.
I think she's like the biggest plushie I own.
I'm not gonna lie.
One-to-one scale.
Says who?
Wait, it says we can do this one, but which one is it?
Hold on.
I have to concentrate.
You guys are distracting me.
Where can we do it on?
Oh, just kidding, we can fill it in.
I didn't realize it was done at the top.
I was like, huh?
What do you mean?
There's nothing there.
Okay, that's that.
Okay.
Let's see.
Not this one.
Distract!
The Fumo told me.
The Fumo's already talking to you?
Uh-oh.
I think we need to... we need to report that.
That's some real...
Some real poltergeist energy.
Let's see.
Three, one, one.
One, two, three.
Two.
Oh, I did it.
Is this Castlevania?
Oh!
Guys.
I might be the most gamer.
This is what happens.
when I put on my glasses.
I can see!
I dropped my controller.
Let's do this one.
So you like Castlevania.
Let's see what we got.
A lot of wines around here.
This one's also clear.
Five, and all the way down, and all the
way...
Akairi Mito!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you, thank you guys.
My brain is just so foggy that it's like, I'm sorry that I,
maybe, well I don't really necessarily, I was only gone for
a couple days, I don't necessarily need a welcome back
stream.
But...
My brain is just so...
Do you wonder why Minto chose the Konami Edition?
Jokes aside, it's crazy how many of these Jupyter released
in between Switch 1 and 2.
Right!
There's so many of these games.
And what's great is they're just so easy, like you just pick
it up and you can do it and...
It's a good time, it's fun.
Did a little, little, little, little, little.
No!
Thank you so much for the...
Oh.
For the...
For the 50 goods and thank you!
Thank you so, so much!
Holy cow.
I like clearing the blues and stuff.
You know?
Makes me feel productive.
Let's see.
One, two, three, four, one.
Okay.
If the music gets annoying though, just let me know.
I know it's kind of like repeating.
Even with a foggy head, you're faster than me?
Because I kind of play these to like chill and relax too,
you know.
No, no grams to relax too.
That's kind of my thing.
Is that right?
One, two, three.
Oh, wait.
I was wrong.
Oh, oops.
Wait, what?
Is there an undo?
It was...
Wait, which one did I...
Actually, wait.
Wait.
Rewind?
Can I do that?
There we go.
Actually, this is done.
Okay, there we go.
Oh, that still stands.
Correct.
One, two.
What is this?
Can you guys tell?
Mysterious.
Mysterious creature.
What are you?
Oh wait.
That's done.
A seal?
What is a seal?
I think.
Seal
Everybody was right Seal You love that guy's songs I'll I'll
I'm a seal
Okay, I'm gonna see how fast I can do this one Hee hee We're
going to challenge myself.
Oh.
Oh, I'm missing all these really obvious ones.
That's funny.
Wait.
Uh.
Let's see.
Oh, this one's done.
Uh.
Let's see.
Oh,
no, wait.
I messed up here.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
I fixed it.
Because there's some four.
I fixed it!
Oh, everybody was trying to tell me.
You play these but you have to manually count?
Me too, don't worry about it.
I do also.
You've been kissed by a rose on the tombstone.
Oh, wait, I was wrong.
Wait, no, I was right.
You've been kissed.
You've been kissed there before.
The rose and the tombstone.
You've been struck by.
You've been kissed by a smooth criminal.
If I committed more crimes, then I could be a smooth
criminal.
Dang it.
I just need to commit more crimes.
And then I gotta go around kissing everybody.
You're first.
Minky, are you okay?
Are you okay?
Are you okay, Minky?
No, I'm a sick cat.
Oh, whoops.
Why?
Why does this keep happening to me?
It's saying I can do something with the seven, but I'm not
quite sure.
Me first!
You know what, while you wait, you can kiss your fellow Ibu.
Look to your left.
Kiss.
Look to your right.
Look above.
Look down.
There's a ceiling?
No, no, no.
There's an eye boo right there.
There's an eye boo all around in you.
Is this kiss the homies hour?
Yeah.
You guys kiss the homies and I'm gonna have a handful of
nudge.
Today's menu is...
Cashew!
Pause.
Cashew.
Oh, sorry, bless you.
Did you see this?
Are these salted?
Maybe a little bit.
Yes.
They are salted.
Okay, okay, wait, I was supposed to do this as fast as I
could and I totally gave up.
Wait!
I was supposed to do this as fast as I could!
Oh, my head hurts so bad, though.
Actually, my head hurts so much.
Wait, did I mess up, though?
Because why is this the only thing that I can do?
But...
I
got distracted by Ivo kissing.
Wouldn't anybody?
It's the X's on the right side.
Oh, I see, I see!
I didn't see this one over here.
I'm blind as heck.
Okay, thank you.
We're back in business, baby.
We're back in business.
We are back in business.
Business is booming even.
Oh, I cleared it.
Wait, what is this?
A penguin?
She has commanded the eyebrows.
Up, up, up.
Down, down, left, right, left, right, be a star.
Ginny, welcome back.
Thank you.
I got a clip one too.
Please, please, please let there be another Metal Gear.
I'm waiting.
Perodious.
Blaze Metal Gear?
Why does Konami have to have so many games?
Kind of messed up if you think about it.
Wait, oops.
Oh, look, not that.
Four, five, wait.
One, two, three, four, five, six.
Eleven.
Are you excited about the Goemon collection?
I've never played ever Goemon in my afterlife before, so I
wouldn't say that I'm excited per se, but I think it's cool.
You know?
I'm excited for people that are excited.
I always love seeing stuff like that happen where it's like,
oh my gosh, this game has five fans and suddenly they're
doing something with the series.
But like, it's like five fans.
Oh wait, I messed that up.
In the West, you know.
There we go.
Taco Bell fans.
Ah!
Thank you.
Crunch up supreme!
Why is $20 so much though?
You appreciate passion.
Yeah, I mean...
Wouldn't anybody?
Five, six, eight.
Yes.
I'm still deciding if I should get...
get a switch to, especially because the prices are going up
again, right?
Wait,
where was it?
Seven, eight, nine, ten, eleven, twelve, eight.
Coming up in September.
Yeah.
Yolo went at some point.
I don't know.
Right now, I'm just kind of like, like, Pocopia seemed fun,
but I don't have time to play right now so it's kind of just
like a I
could add anything that I would want with it you know what I
mean like
delivery fee no no delivery they
say they all say that and Nintendo drops a new guy yeah I
know but also at the same time I'm like I don't know.
I feel like so many things I could get.
What the heck was that?
So many things I can get on Steam at the moment.
Minus like, you know, Pokemon or whatever.
But I just don't have time to play it at the moment.
Put it on the business card.
Business.
I mean, it would be.
It would be going on the business card.
At the business expensive I've ever heard of one.
I don't even have the OLED switch, you know?
So I was thinking, oh, maybe if I, like, want to upgrade or
something.
I don't know.
Like, if I upgrade, I would then just get the switch.
Wait.
Oh, yeah.
Switch 2 instead.
I'm still on my Animal Crossing switch.
Wait, the screen on the OLED switch is better than what's on
the switch 2?
You're kidding right now.
Well, ain't that just funny?
Maybe I'll wait for the OLED version of the Switch 2 then.
Oh!
That's crazy.
That's actually craziness.
Switch 2.5.
Oh, yeah.
And this is 3.
Oh, oops.
Switch 3?
I'll wait for the Switch 3.
So true.
Yeah, you're so right.
Why should I get anything else?
I'll wait for the brand newest technology.
I'll always just wait for the newest thing.
Once the Switch 3 comes out...
No, no, no.
I need the Switch 4.
Yes.
Oh, is that what I meant to do?
There we go.
Oh wait, we don't know for certain there.
Unless I'm just slow and haven't seen it yet.
Yes.
There we go.
Wait a bit.
What?
This music is so stupid.
Beep, beep, beep, beep.
Is this it?
Yeah.
That's a car.
Players Jeep.
Let me home from Grid AFM Surgery I'm officially not going
to have a blood vessel Burst and die Whoa That's good Silver
Dimes Get better soon Speedly recovery
Silver Linus What is Jackal?
I don't know this game
all sorts getting patched up around your eyes for real
actually right pirate
I missed the first half of the stream can you summarize your
trip in three words wait where's my phone the
noise I heard it was my phone dropping what
does this mean let's see my trip I have two things that I
needed to go for and I accomplished both so that was really
great um the the puppets have been handed off to Steiner so
they will make their way to Faname for the uh for the um
auction yeah actually I went through three things and i got
all three things done um oh you did uh we got our uh our
deco checky things we did that um after that uh off collab
actually we went to the uh do you guys know uh arena
tanemura she's a she's a manga artist and and um we went to
her exhibit.
She did like, Fulmoon and what was it?
Kaito
Kaito Kamijin?
Wait, hold on, I'm going to look up the names.
She does very Shoujo manga.
And so after the off collab, we went to go see her exhibit
together.
Oh, Kamikaze Kaitojin.
And Fulmoon.
Yeah, Phantom Thief.
Jean?
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
But I only know full moon.
I only know full moon, but that was like, that was like one
of my favorite series ever.
Actually the first ever YouTube video I ever uploaded was me
singing a cover of that song.
It is long- I don't even know where that video went, but...
Let's see.
She did...
She's done quite a...
Quite a bit.
Oh, that's why somebody said Idolish 7.
She did the character designs.
But...
Um...
Release the Moy files.
Can we see it?
I don't know.
I don't have it anymore.
I don't have it anymore at all.
I don't know where that is.
It's gone.
Long gone eaten by the internet.
It was like my first ever, ever, ever, ever, ever YouTube
video.
But I did a cover of that.
And so yeah, we went to that.
It was really, really nice.
I remembered how little I remember of the series.
but it was fun we went oh yeah that's right Vicky was
posting on on Twitter she was just like I'm in Miami but she
didn't go to Miami actually we went to Enoshima one of my
favorite places ever you need to sing more Fudamuno,
Sagastay and karaoke okay next time I will I will sing more
I promise I pinky promise your promise, break your pick.
But yeah.
Chew hard.
Yeah, we weren't in Miami.
Shocker.
Abs, everybody.
We fooled you.
We fooled you all.
We've been had.
This is probably what your brain sounded like.
when you found out, you were like,
.
Does not compute.
My brain always sounds like going on music.
Why is this, the songs are actually like three seconds long.
It's kind of driving me insane.
Like, big fan, but please.
Can they last for, like, any more amount of time?
Played us like a darn fiddle!
Yeah.
And I'll do it again.
And I do it again.
What else did we?
Oh, yeah, we went to Endoshima.
It was really, really nice.
It was actually Phoebe's first time.
And it was a super nice day.
And we got to do a lot of stuff.
We ate a cafe.
and we walked around a lot and we went in the cave and paid
our tributes to the dragon god.
Are you gonna watch the Summer Game Fest?
Just in case I accidentally bothered you about it.
No, don't say that.
Uh, what is it?
Summer Game Fest.
June 5th.
Wait, I think I will be able to watch.
Yeah, I'll put it on my schedule.
Did you get attacked by birds?
No, this time!
Yeah!
So great.
No birds attacking.
Summer Games Fest.
What time is it at?
La la la.
Summer Game Fest.
Friday.
What time?
Oh, 5 p.m.
ED.
Okay, okay, okay.
I got it.
Bird curse broken.
Actually, I've never been attacked by the birds there.
Now that I think about it.
I've never been attacked by the birds.
Are you guys getting attacked?
So I used combat 8 in there, so I hope it shows up.
I'm sure it will.
I feel like it would.
Can't believe the dragon goddess chill like that.
I met his turtle and everything.
He's super chill Super chill guy one two three four five six
The music Why did the music pick up after that
After six there is no number after six there is no number
after six You are hallucinating.
You
are hallucinating.
Six and a half.
Actually, all numbers have ceased to exist.
Hmm.
It's always difficult going from a P-cross, like...
What's the word?
Um...
Like...
board that I'm used to into a different one.
Because I have to readjust my eyes to everything.
You know what I mean?
I think I'm starting to lose to the jet lag already though.
I'm so weak!
But also, my head hurts.
Is it okay if today's stream is a little shorter, you guys?
Peacross without numbers is gonna be tough.
Yeah, wait, Peacross without numbers.
I just wanted to, like, say...
Hi.
That I just wanted to talk.
But at the same time, my throat hurts so much.
I think it's just...
I feel so bad.
Let me show you a creature that we saw at Anoshima.
I wish we could unsee him.
In fact.
I think...
It might be...
It was really terrible.
We saw merch of this guy.
And then we were like...
Then we were going home and we saw him.
like what is this thing do
you have the ice cream yes i did oh my gosh they have a gene
store that sells gene ice cream they sell gene nikuban and
gene ice cream and i ate the gene ice cream and it was just
as delicious as i remembered it last time it tastes like
it's like kind of tangy how do you say the
the milk after a cereal it was made from meat yeah it tasted
like jeans if I get a new pair of jeans and I I don't know
that's what exactly what it tastes like blended up denim
here hold on okay so this is the creature it looks really
bad from the front but I I I swear to you it's even worse
from the side.
Oh god, sorry.
Oh god, I'm so sorry.
Let me show you from the side.
Like, look at the tail.
Disgusting.
Oh my god.
And it was just like in some... Get it off the screen.
Very deserving of the title, The Creature.
There was merch of him, but it was like drawn merch.
And we were like, oh, this thing is kind of freaky.
And then we went to...
It was just in some like art setup.
I don't know.
Do you call that art?
At the train station.
Everybody had to see it.
Families, children.
Everyone was subjected to it.
It's terrifying.
It's terrible.
This music makes this nightmare of fuel.
Yeah.
So definitely saw that guy.
Was not a fan.
It doesn't evoke a unique emotion.
Elden Ring mini boss.
Also, I went to...
I did go to a maid cafe.
But not like a maid maid cafe.
Honestly, I'm kind of like, what did I do?
this trip because i guess i was like kind of busy trying to
get stuff done um but i went to cure made cafe and they had
a re-zero collaboration which i was like re-zero um i got i
got amelia's Carbonara.
Hold on, I can show a picture.
Beatrice's drink.
Which was pretty dang good.
Wait, hold on.
Let's see.
It was...
The Carbonara was so good because it had like little...
What's the word?
Oh, I also got... There was like a special anniversary
drink.
I forgot I got that too.
Let me see.
so this is me this is me and the Beatrice Betty drink oh it
like had whipped cream with her with her hair bows I was
like I was taking notes I was like I need inspo for if I
ever do another collab cafe I grabbed some jeans to chew on
now it tasted really bland you got out The seasoning, then.
You got on the seasoning.
But yeah, this was really cute.
But it was carbonated.
It was delicious, but carbonated.
So I could only have a little bit.
Yeah, the bows were candy.
But luckily I got the other drink.
It was like a tea.
And then...
Did I say this one?
And then the carbonara.
Brrr.
was Amelia labored.
I'm not sure why what the purple was.
But the the little fried bits were supposed to be like the
little ears on her cape, on her hood and uh, on her cape
hood.
they were fried cheese.
And those were the best part.
Those were so good.
I don't know what the purple was.
Maybe it was like food color.
Maybe it was like beet.
I don't know.
Yeah, I was fried cheese.
That was delicious.
What else did I do?
I went shopping for clothes.
I got my hair done.
You probably can't tell, though.
I went haunting a little bit as some shrines.
Um...
I went to get my hair done and they were like, it'll take a
couple hours.
And it took three and a half hours.
No, I didn't get a haircut.
I got a treatment done on it.
So it was like... So now it's even silkier.
So can you tell?
The way it...
Well, it just flows the way it does because I'm dead, but
also because it's silkier.
Minto cuteness tax funds proceeds go to future developments,
research, and update of the cuteness and happiness of Minto.
Thank you, Gappa!
And then after we finished all that we needed to finish,
After that, we went to Disney!
We went to Disney Sea together.
And that was also Phoebe's first time going.
So I had a lot of fun being everybody's tour guide a little
bit.
They would be like, Mito, your professional opinion.
What should we do next?
Disney!
Yeah, that was fun.
I recommend anybody to go to Disney Sea because it's quite
honestly one of the most beautiful parks in my opinion like
one of the most beautiful theme parks but also I was like yo
you guys we need to go on this ride it's so awesome and who
is this little kid Princess Yudi A lot of going, mon.
Disney Sea is so amazing.
And, uh...
I was like, we gotta go on this ride, it's awesome.
And Steiner was just like, I don't know.
I don't know.
And I was like, no, trust.
It's the best ride.
So it's called...
It's the Sinbad ride at Princess...
Oh, sorry.
At Disney.
At Poincennes.
was at Disney Sea, and it's Sinbad.
And here are my reasons why it's so amazing.
One, it is all reliable.
the ride is, the wait time is always like five minutes long.
You can get on at any time.
It's, it's, you're cold and you want to get inside, go on
Sinbad.
You're hot and you want a nice dark ride that will cool you
down, get on Sinbad.
Then, The ride has such a good song!
It's so good!
The song is like emotional and sounds awesome.
It's like it's a small world times a million.
The song is awesome.
It is so so good.
So I highly recommend it.
The third reason it's great is because the animatronics on
it are really good.
They're really awesome.
Like, I don't want to spoil.
but some of them are really big and everything else everyone
is so expressive and it's awesome and then the last reason
it's so good is because it's so long so it's only a five
minute wait but imagine you've been walking around the park
all day you're so tired or you're hot because it's
summertime you're like i gotta go on this ride five minute
wait and the ride itself is like Like, oh my gosh, it's
probably almost over.
No, you have another 10 minutes.
It's so awesome.
It's like the best ride that could ever exist.
That sounds so OP for a ride.
I'm not even kidding.
Like, it's actually so good.
BRB headed to the Sinbad ride.
Yeah!
The song is so cute.
Hold on.
Oh, sorry.
I didn't mean to do that.
Okay, hold on.
I'm gonna, I wonder if I can find a karaoke of it.
Let's see.
Sinbad.
Wait, did, was that really loud?
So I'm sorry.
I'm sorry.
Oh.
Okay.
Sinbad.
Disney karaoke.
no no not zippity do though no not Aladdin wait what is it
even called okay hold on sin bad Tokyo Disney song compass
of your heart okay okay okay
your heart.
Sinbad.
Oh my god.
In English!
Wait, there's a- there's a- there's the same thing in
English?
Okay, hold on.
Karaoke.
No!
I can't find it.
Okay, I'll do an acapella.
Okay.
Mate!
Hold on.
Maybe this is it.
Is the song actually six minutes long?
If that gives you any indication.
Oh no, it's muted.
Or am I muted?
Oh, I'm muted.
Wait, I have to get rid of the game.
so I can hear it.
Oh my god.
I was muted.
It's such a cute song.
Okay, hold on.
I'm going to sing it now.
Compass.
Compass of your heart.
Okay.
Oh, wait.
Why is it in English?
Kashi.
Kashi is lyrics in Japanese.
FYI.
It's just us mint in the void.
Yep.
Actually, I like my slippers.
of your heart.
Did I find it?
Is this song really that long?
What the heck?
It's so low.
I'm the one controlling it, but it's slow.
Wait,
where am I?
Wait, actually I don't know the way it goes.
Actually, I don't know the...
Okay,
I'm gonna skip to where I do know.
Okay, I'm gonna skip to where I do know.
Sorry that was my controller.
Compass of your heart.
How do I read that?
Wait, how do I read that?
Wait, am I with the robot?
I finally found it.
I don't know.
I think I got it.
it i think i got it
i wonder there's english lyrics but i wonder if i could
figure it out in english lift your sails to the heavens and
fly on the breeze steer straight toward the horizon Seek
brand new seas.
Life's awaiting you out there.
And if you sail true, you may find a priceless treasure out
there too.
Wait, what's the second part?
Tides may turn you and toss you and storms may arise.
Harm may stand in the path where your destiny lies.
Just reach out for a friend.
lost and astray let the compass of your heart show you the
way life is the greatest adventure there is no map there's
no chart but if you seek life's great adventure follow the
compass of your
oh and then he's like
what does he say wait hold on let me find it where is it I'm
looking where is the lyrics wait
I think I found it oh oh I lost it oh where did I go Wait,
huh?
Wait, I just scrolled just a tiny bit and I lost it.
Oh, wait, I lost it.
It's such a good song.
Trust me, trust me, trust me.
The minto that knows good things.
You can always trust my...
I'm sorry.
You can always trust my opinion.
Sorry, I was going ghost a little bit there.
I think I'm done with P-Cross.
I wish I could sing this song.
I wish I could show you.
I wish I could sing it for you.
Help you feel better soon.
Glad you're back on a big happy birthday to both Shirokos.
Happy birthday to both Shinokas!
I'm gonna put on BGM.
Thanks for streaming today, Mindo.
Hope you feel better soon.
I'm really sorry I keep getting sick.
I hope.
I haven't played.
Actually, whenever I travel, I get really bad about playing
Blue Archive.
I'm not sure why.
I'm just so bad at doing my dailies.
Baby Cori, thank you so much for the vibe.
Get that.
I'm gonna blow my nose.
I'm so sorry.
I can't do it anymore.
I can't resist the temptation of my lotioned...
These are not my lotion tissues!
These are the other ones, the flushable ones.
Did
Acapella during my end credits?
What do you mean?
You inspired me to get Taco Bell today.
Thank you.
I'll feed some to the Mini Minto as payment.
Thank you very much for your offering.
Please, if you ever are wondering what to offer, Minto...
Taco Bell.
Taco Bell is always a good option.
To paraphrase a great streamer, stop getting sick!
I wish!
And garlic, oh yeah.
I'm a garlic girl.
I'm gonna go take us some more medicine.
Or my nose.
Can you wiggle your nose?
I always tried to do that.
I'm not a genie, but I always wanted to be.
How do you do it?
I can wiggle my knees.
I can do that too.
Well, it kind of looks like I have to party, right?
Wiggle them knees.
Oh yeah.
You can wiggle your ears?
Well, kind of.
I can't wiggle my...
I can't wiggle my actual ears.
I can't do it.
But I can wiggle my cat ears.
Taco!
You need longer ears to wiggle them?
What if one day I develop the ability to wiggle them though.
Can you hit the DreamWorks smirk face?
Oh, wait, that was pretty good!
Wait, I did it once, I can't do it again.
I
kind of, I feel like that...
What's that meme of that guy that like has his pockets?
He's got his hands in his pockets and he's kind of like
looking like a little smug like that at the the camera it's
from a tv show
kevin james that's is that it kevin yeah the chill guy that
sounds right
wait yes yes yes yes him wait a second i think i can do it
Was that good?
Were we both so chill?
One to one?
I'm seeing double.
Chill and chill.
Could be twins.
My long-lust brother.
I always wanted a brother.
The Minky of Queens.
What was the show even about?
Hold on.
queens I'll read you I will read you Wikipedia Doug Hefner
hefner hefrenner hefrenner Doug Hefrenner puts in a long
day's work delivering parcels and comes home each night to
his loving wife Carrie unfortunately he also comes home to
his wacko father-in-law, Arthur.
Doug's only refuge are the little time he spends alone with
Carrie in the company of his buddy Spence, co-worker Deacon,
and cousin Danny, whom he turns to advice that just might
make his life better if he only bothered to follow it.
This sounds like a show of the era.
His stepfather was George Costanza's father.
Oh, no way!
He plays mall cop.
I did know that.
What an interesting thing to join stream to.
Hi Mimi!
I'm reading about the king of queens.
I don't think he's a king of anything.
Oh, I do see!
I do see that...
Oh, it's George Costanza.
Or not George Costanza.
George Costanza's...
Dodd.
Oh.
Wait, he is a Ben Stiller's...
Ben Stiller is a Nepo baby?
Wow.
Ben Stiller's real name is Benjamin Stiller.
So it's not Ben Stiller.
Most actors are, you think so?
What about me?
I'm not a nipple baby.
I worked all of this on my own.
I got this far.
Oh.
Mint is just a baby.
I started with no help.
No help.
I'm the definition of no help.
Okay, Ben Stiller, stop looking at me.
Also, this guy.
Stop looking at me.
Get me Kevin James.
Reminder that Ben Stiller directed Severance.
I know!
It's kind of cool.
Why am I hanging out here?
Should I go to my room?
Nah, I like the void.
It's quiet here.
The comfort void.
Mito Imo.
Why are we in the void?
i guess i'll end stream now i guess that's why i don't know
my brain is so foggy i'm like one thought goes through my
ear and out the other at the moment um well i'll see you
guys tomorrow i'll stream tomorrow too thank
you guys hi da hi da try for the thank you i missed the
first half of the stream so can you oh sorry oh i've i've
read the wrong thing.
Welcome back.
Thank you for the fun streams.
They always give everyone energy boosts to their day.
Oh, I'm really happy.
I'm sorry, though, that I am so so
but I hope you guys still had fun.
Tomorrow will be a little more structured, so.
Darko, thank you so much for the peek.
It's important to rest when you're sick.
Thanks for the song and silly fun.
I hope you guys had fun.
Which ear does it exit?
Thanks for the streaming, don't welcome back.
Thank you!
Thanks you!
You're so cute, welcome home.
Don't feel better soon.
Thank you, say sir!
Look at that, thank you!
Thanks for streaming even sync.
Sync?
I am sync!
I will stream even when I am sync.
My nose feels like a sync.
I got so much ectoplasm coming out.
Down with the sinkness.
So far, welcome to membership.
Thank you so much.
My streamer is sinking the head.
I hope you guys don't get sick.
Feel good.
I will see you when I see you next.
tomorrow sorry for the shorter stream it's always like this
after I get back from crypto the jet lag wins I am I am a
loser to the jet hag thank you guys so much thank you thank
you thank you thank you
I think I'm gonna sneeze I don't want to because it hurts my
throat are
you gonna count all those chickens before they hatch.
Right in our faces?
Yeah, I'll get closer even.
No worries on short stream.
We miss you.
It was wonderful to see you.
Welcome home.
Thank you!
Okay, I'll get it far away.
Distance, distance.
Ugh, I hope.
Wait.
Tch!
Ultramainto.
Bye-bye!
Thank you!
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye!
Bye-bye!
Eat the next time!
Thank you!
Thanks for the more, welcome back!
Bye-bye!